supongamos que me dan una transformación
que va del conjunto x en el conjunto y
les recuerdo que una transformación es
sencillamente otra terminología para la
palabra función así que bien aquí tengo
mi dominio x único dominio ye y la
transformación lo único que hace es
asociarme a un elemento en x con un
elemento en jeff y bien vamos a suponer
que además tengo un subconjunto a de x
esta anotación
lo que significa es subconjunto
su conjunto
perfecto entonces nosotros habíamos
dicho vamos a decir que esto es sano
tortillas am entonces nosotros dijimos
que te vea
era la imagen de a
imagen
bajo la transformación de bajo
y como un conjunto lo que era
el conjunto pues lo que hacíamos era nos
tomábamos todos los x que pertenecían a
y nos fijábamos en tdx trx pertenece a
iu porque es un elemento del dominio
entonces bien en otras palabras quién es
este conjunto pues simplemente tomó un
elemento en x digo en un elemento en a y
lo envió a algún elemento en la
transformación te lo envía a algún
elemento en que toma otro punto y veo
que le hace la transformación por
ejemplo lo podría regresar a este mismo
punto
y tomó todos los elementos de a y
obtengo otro conjunto en este caso en su
conjunto
es la imagen de a
bajo t ahora bien qué pasa si considera
el problema al revés
qué pasa si empezando en que yo me fijo
en algún subconjunto ese que mikko
dominio y quiero encontrar los miembros
de x que se transforman o que son
enviados a elementos de ese es decir en
otras palabras estoy buscando el
conjunto de los x mx tales que la
transformación aplicada a x pertenezca
al conjunto cual subconjunto s bien si
hago eso entonces lo que estoy haciendo
es tratando de encontrar los puntos
los puntos de aquí los puntos de x estar
aquí es
y se transforman
puntos de ese este viene a dar acá
digamos que estoy bien acá
y esos puntos forman un subconjunto de
textos
ahora bien quiero ser enfático en algo
no todos los puntos de s tienen que
provenir de algún punto en x por ejemplo
este punto podría no ser la imagen de
ningún punto del conjunto x así que hay
que tener cuidado pero bien esté aquí
este conjunto aquí se denota por t al
menos uno de s
y se llama la pre imagen
la imagen
respecto
y esto tiene sentido porque al fijarnos
en la imagen de un subconjunto del
dominio veíamos a dónde se iba al
fijarnos en la pre imagen de un
subconjunto del co dominio lo que nos
estamos preguntando es de dónde viene
ok ahora por puntos extra tiene es la
imagen
de la pre imagen del conjunto s ya esta
pregunta tiene un pequeño truco para
empezar quién es la prima gen esta parte
de aquí
es la prima gen de ese en este caso
sería este conjunto morado de aquí esto
sería de al menos 1 de s
ahora bien a dónde se transforma pues
todos sus puntos todos sus miembros por
definición se transforman en elementos
de ese pero
aquí está la parte extraña no todos los
elementos de s tienen que provenir de
elementos de la pre imagen por ejemplo
este punto verde aquí habíamos dicho que
no provenía de ningún elemento en x así
que si le aplicó la imagen a puntos de
aquí como están en x ninguno le pega al
punto verde así que a lo mucho puedo
decir que esto está contenido en el
conjunto s y quizás aquí viene esta
anotación de inversa para la pre imagen
del hecho de que estas dos la imagen y
la pre imagen en cierto sentido se
cancelan también es muy interesante pero
este se los dejo de tarea considerar
quien es la pre imagen de la imagen de
un subconjunto del dominio pero bueno
todo esto estuvo muy abstracto en el
próximo vídeo voy a dar un ejemplo
concreto donde calcular el apre imagen
de un conjunto